[Music]
and
indian news oh i like india all right
well
actually let me ask you guys this we're
going back to old jk times
huh oh jk news i know we haven't done
the in whatever news
you guys used to be our format yeah sure
but yeah so tbt
oh that's okay how do you guys if your
marriage was or the idea of marriage in
current day
was to be in arranged marriages i'll do
it
how do you feel about that nope i don't
like it
but these because my mom picked some
ugly ass girl
potentially could be very hot no
actually my mom picked some pretty cute
girls but i just wasn't ready for them
that's right i don't
you're making it work i don't like it
because i already know
what it's like i already know that we
don't have to do that
you know like if if it was my whole life
leading up to that then i probably
wouldn't have a problem with it more
nice right now we've known the luxury of
picking yourself
having a lover right yeah but i mean it
is interesting well what if she could
like
hook you up though you know what i mean
like
what if like she could hook you up with
someone that you can't get yourself well
like that indian matchmaking show on
netflix
oh there's this lady who like was fixing
up but um
i don't know it's just yeah we're too
spoiled we're too spoiled at this point
like we know what it's like
well if i can have an arranged marriage
but then have people on the side that i
can just [ __ ]
then i want no emotional connection so
that's an arrangement
[ __ ] so you have an arrangement i'm done
with that so you're like royalty with
concubines
right yeah because one's a business
transaction for my family my wealth all
that
and then the other one is just for me
right what what about like family
on duty and stuff like this like
you said but like in arranged marriages
like a lot of times you know it's
appropriate
yeah parents pair you up with another
family that
you know is you become the property
that's what i mean it's a business
transaction
transaction so basically you're just
with the arranged marriage and then you
do it
to please the parents you have the baby
because i want that business to flourish
so i'll give myself
because you're not a quitter i'm not
it's like game of thrones like she's
like a princess of switzerland and then
like she's getting married to like the
king of
[ __ ] germany i'm here to win baby no
matter what i want to win we want to win
the game
that's it we want to win on the side
what's that one katherine the great
that's what she wants to be
i'm going to russia and bang the prince
there and then become the ruler of
russia
yeah wait but then okay so she had a
concubine
his name was i don't know i forgot his
name he changed it a little bit but
we'll go ahead
yeah right right i'm not uh yeah i know
nothing
what the catherine the grey was from
russia i wanna i wanna think about the
logistics here
so then you're married business yep
part of the business is to create kids
yep and just
make your family move up in life yeah
right but then like the [ __ ] on the
side
um that's also a business no like how do
you prevent
like that side [ __ ] to be your the the
it's an arranged side [ __ ] wait oh like
the father of your offspring because
then if you're [ __ ] oh
i mean i would i would use protection
for sure like we're still in now time
okay because i'm thinking old times yeah
but you become a snow is what happens a
bastard
you become a snow a snow like a jon snow
tim already remember the last time i
said i haven't really watched the office
as much and tim
punched me in the face i tried game of
thrones and i haven't finished i just
literally i did that i just watched like
three i watched like three episodes
total wow you're on the fence right
maybe four maybe five finishing time
it was a pandemic i think khaleesi
emilia
amelia clark and also the other one um
is the
boy son i like the red head oh i love
red head so much
the boy's son is really cute too there's
some really hot people on that ned stark
natalie manuel is like one of my [ __ ]
boys what are you talking about jon snow
no not that one the one that
uh has the dark curly hair jon snow
that's no no not that one jon snow
that's strong
not the little kid who fell off the
building jon snow you're talking about
john
i guess that one the only other one
right they had oh the one that was
the boy in a wheelchair
all right arrange marriages revising the
question about arranged marriages
uh if you had say uh x amount of time
like say two dates to get to know your
future husband because
how arranged marriages i looked it up
how it usually works
is you kind of have two dates and
supervised by your parents both sides of
the family
if you have two dates what are the
questions what are the things you need
to know before you commit yourself and
arrange marriages you have the right to
veto this oh
okay so it's not it's not forced to
arrange marriage it's
arranged marriage so you have the right
to be like no
i don't like this guy oh so then the
parent provides suitors yes
and you got the ball together right
right right oh yeah i think that's what
i've seen on the team i would be like
mom make sure you find someone that eats
ass please
gotcha but talking to the to your
potential uh partner
what do what do you ask them what oh
yeah yeah you like the rusty trombone i
love it that's a deal breaker that's
right
right the other one is um do you love
your life
oh damn those are
very very complicated if they say no and
i'm like well [ __ ] you stay away from me
right because bad vibes bad vibes
to filter through the [ __ ] it's like
speed dating but speed dating it answers
so much though that question alone do
you love your life
no because then it's okay bye bye
run away run but they can also just like
not be
completely honest and vulnerable with
that question because it's so
like it can be very deep well i have it
on contract because then
if she isn't then i'll be like you're a
lying sack of [ __ ] i'm voiding this man
yeah i don't think i've ever had that
ass to me do you love your life
yeah i've said i love my life i've said
it i don't need anyone to ask babies
basically i don't need anyone to ask
then i don't have to ask the question
i'll have another question for you
which is do you like eggs love eggs
oh actually you know what i will say
that as a deal breaker tells you
everything i will say
like something for me and my future
partner like someone who isn't a picky
eater
yeah that's basically the question yeah
yeah [ __ ] picky
sometimes it's like you know and being
asian we know there's like
so many dishes that are so like guts
yeah exotic dishes contestants from big
contestants
from because that's just a big feat you
know
um that is not a deal breaker i bet
i'm a [ __ ] picky eater i bet i would
still score a date
oh first of all that's the second time
geo has flirted with me
bart is not here oh you said
you said i'm 38 you would date me oh we
would date i said i
i keep it in the [ __ ] log machine
it looks like a strong flirt yeah oh for
sure okay no no i'm sorry not okay two
why
two though good things come in three
well you don't need to you don't need to
eat the pig feet the crazy stuff for
like uh eating pork eating beef like i i
have a lot of
um yeah pescetarians vegans and stuff
and it's like
it's not a big problem but uh just
knowing things that my mom cooks and
bringing someone home
you know what i mean it'd be cool if
they liked um all because what if
they're like
that's not gluten free is it i can't eat
your [ __ ] mom
i wouldn't mind a picky obviously
because i'm a big eater but um
i would mind if like i bring them home
to my parents
and then they're [ __ ] putting in
their own opinions about like they just
don't go with the flow that shoots
right go with the flow if you don't eat
gluten [ __ ] you are today
i don't care if you're gonna have an
allergic reaction and die get the tums
i mean if it's that of course right
right right
if they're not trying to go with the
flow with the collective i'm like bye
right
yeah too difficult right so in india
uh a recently married couple uh
because through arranged marriage uh the
27 year old
wife is now filing the case of breach of
trust
against her husband who hid the fact
that he was
bald that is a [ __ ]
[ __ ] some people might really want that
is that is that a
make or break marriage yeah what if i
had no dick and i didn't tell her that
and then
that's a little we got together and
she's like hold on
version but yeah what if you you had a
toupee for pubes
oh like it flaps up and down she thought
you had views why would you and you
faked that you had no pubes switch it up
you know wait on this head or ball down
that head
balled on the dick okay now that's where
he took it balls
on this one that's where she does maybe
for her it's the principal
i think it's the principal yeah don't
lie to me from the jump but
this is why i asked like how do you
speed date during your
few dates that you had before marriage
right how do you get to that point to
find out if you're bold or not you know
what i had to ask the right question
in the mail in the man's defense like i
will say that
that's something that he does to enhance
his looks
correct women do that as well it's like
it's like if she takes off her bra and
her tits are very small
kind of the same situation being like is
there anything about you that
you you hide to the world but you
that i should know that you should
reveal to me
oh but it's not going to cut to the
chase but i mean that could be many
things but what if he's like i actually
don't like bananas and my mom always
makes me
and he's like oh my god like i'll be
like focused
now your turn
[Laughter]
oh i wear makeup you know like well i
don't know what i look like the world
proceeds from you
right that i should no i'm trying to
think if i have any of those
um secrets i think it's a hard one for
the room just because like
there's like a vibe and an energy and
just like a demeanor that people give
off you know like when you're talking to
them like you're being supervised
yeah that's true you're on your best
behavior oh you're supervised
yeah and these arranged marriages right
the parents are there
interesting is it one of those things
where the parents are just chilling and
then like you walk around
you guys kind of have your space or like
the parents like walking around
following you
because to be honest i don't know i'll
be honest something i will say
especially with the parents there it's
gonna be hard to ask questions like
would you go down on girls
you know what i mean cause that's a deal
breaker this is a deal breaker
that's true so so that is an absolute
deal breaker so it's like is that like a
second date question of the two or is
that like that is like
nice to meet you and then yeah you got
after a handshake
like you you'll ask do you eat [ __ ] and
i'll be like yeah do you eat ass
right it's like okay what if a girl like
didn't uh give blow jobs
is there such a thing
as oh [ __ ] i mean i didn't know
it would be a deal breaker for you i
didn't
no only rusty only
oh no actually no yes uh rusty trombone
because the hand is doing the the penis
the mouth is doing it yes yes um just
paint a picture
but i don't know but that's just also
like wow what
maybe in that happens maybe in the
indian arranged marriage
world there's some handshake the thing
you do like like you just tell each
other like are you [ __ ]
oh that'd be smart you know what i mean
like a wink wink
but they would know because they were
once young right but it changed it
evolved every generation has it it's
like it's like dance moves you know from
the jerk to the you know
yeah did you ever hear about that that
one thing because i remember being
like in high school or middle school is
like some younger [ __ ]
but like if you shake hands with the
person and that if the person
they put the middle finger inside your
present that means they're trying to
[ __ ] you no one's ever done that to me
it's only yeah i remember that i
remember that joke i remember being that
[ __ ] like in elementary or something i
remember that people would you would do
it to me but i don't think they might
like it i was like oh gross it does give
me like kind of chills maybe in a good
way i don't know
gross me behind the locker anyway so
yeah this woman uh she filed the
complaint against her husband
the police have asked the husband to
surrender himself and his toupee
yep and come out come out put the debate
down the in-laws confronted
yeah it starts running out the the
toupee has a mug shot
just sideways you get super like your
[ __ ] frauds and then the in-laws are
also been slapped with a
uh they've been booked under because
they say breach of trust and defamation
now
as well so this is actually been taken
up to a few notches of
gotta be the most embarrassing thing for
this dude to be going through
right now like his parents are getting
brought in for his like toupee
i don't know i mean honestly i didn't i
don't know it's just a weird story i
have no idea how to
imagine you're in jail and they're like
what are you in for
i had a toupee and they're like
[ __ ]
and they beat his ass oh it's like the
horse or they like relate they're like
us too
foreign